le sénat la droite sénatoriale a commis
une faute une faute politique
ils ont déployé un arsenal pour
organiser le blocage de la révision
constitutionnelle
nous étions nous avions fait un
compromis un compromis quasiment
historique sénat l'assemblée à
l'assemblée nationale entre la droite et
la gauche ça n'avait coûté très cher à
la gauche de le faire très cher en terme
de débats sur les valeurs etc
mais nous estimions globalement aux deux
tiers de l'assemblée ce qui n'est pas
rien quand on connaît les débats à
l'assemblée que cela était nécessaire
pour avoir la réforme constitutionnelle
qui est un élément de la lutte contre le
terrorisme
il n'était pas anormal que la droite
sénatoriale reprennent ce texte est la
dope en tant que tel mais des débats
subalternes aurait dit le général de
gaulle peuvent provoquer par la primaire
de la droite maison eu 10 aliments qui
aujourd'hui sur le dit moi je dis je de
vermeil du président à le dire la clarté
pour nos concitoyens
ce débat ne procède pas de ce qui serait
nécessaire pour notre pays mais de la
volonté de se distancier du vote émis à
l'assemblée nationale qui avait le
soutien de nicolas sarkozy
je trouve sa part raisonnable je trouve
que le sénat et je le dis au président
du sénat à la chambre haute qui l'ont
commis une erreur politique par ce
blocage
qu'est ce qui va se passer à présent je
n'en sais rien qu'est-ce que puisque
l'été vous aujourd'hui moi je n'en sais
rien il faut maintenant que si cela
permettait à les renvoyer vers vous mais
non non non non mais moi je n'en sais
rien et vous si vous permettez je crois
qu'il est nécessaire que la droite
sénatoriale est clair le tapis et 10
est ce qu'ils sont pour aller au congrès
ou pour créer les conditions de la
discorde dans l'ensemble des formations
politiques
on n'est plus dans la question de la
patrie dit tu vas pas très belle ville
est très bien vu
c'est un prétexte on avait fait le
compromis quasiment historique à
l'assemblée nationale ils pouvaient
parfaitement le reprendre il y a là un
prétexte
c'est une faute politique et s'il devait
y avoir un consensus pour prendre un
amendements d'abrogation supprimer
l'article 2 sur la déchéance de
nationalité ça ne ça ne vous dirai pas
mais moi je ne dis pas ça mais je dis
est ce que le sénat dans ces conditions
vous avez entendu monsieur bah va pas
réintroduire des éléments dans l'article
dans la deuxième navette donc la
question qui est posée est ce que la
droite sénatoriale et singulièrement le
président du sénat et pour aller au
congrès pour voter un texte où il ne
l'est pas lui nous répond parce qu'ils
étaient en plateau
cette semaine et nous dit qu'il l'est
pour ce compromis de la recherche du
compromis
bon alors il y à une navette il le dit
très clairement il réunit ses troupes et
il or dit il faut voter sinon je mets
mon mandat en jeu son mandat en jeu oui
nous ça veut dire quoi pour vous ça veut
dire que il dit à l'ensemble de ses amis
que c'est c'est une question nécessaire
comme que il met son lay pèse de tout
son poids et certains sur la droite
sénatoriale
on peut pas biaisé sur ces questions là
on peut pas jouer on peut pas faire de
la politique politicienne
il faut être à la hauteur de l'événement
et je trouve que là la droite
sénatoriale a singulièrement était dans
le désert raisonnable le jeu en vaut la
chandelle à congrès ça vaut le coup tout
cela mais l'article 1 des cas urgents de
l'état d'urgence dans la constitution
c'est une mesure qui avait préconisé
monsieur balladur vous rendez compte
dans quelle situation on est une mesure
pour que préconisé par monsieur balladur
est remis en cause par l'ensemble de la
droite et puis un compromis que monsieur
jacob des républicains à accepter et
même voter est remis en cause par la
droite sénatoriale mais on marche sur la
tête comment voulez vous que les
français puissent comprendre que nous
soyons dans cette situation qu'est-ce
qu'on donne comme image de la
représentation parlementaire
si nous sommes tous impactés par ce jeu
politicien ti ce pardon ou leur demander
d'arrêter de jouer
oui fois
était de jouer il faut dire s'ils
veulent aller au congrès s'il veulent
pas aller au congrès belle affaire va se
terminer mais s'ils veulent aller au
congrès alors c'est simple le texte de
l'assemblée nationale est déjà un
compromis sur lequel tout le monde peut
se mettre d'accord